well joining us now is the chair of
Rhema Community Council who has met the
queen several times and met King Charles
II just last Sunday in Bremer hello T
thanks for joining us on the program
tell us about meeting the king last week
well last Sunday we had a special
concert at St Margaret's an old church
in Braemar to celebrate the 30th
anniversary of Classic FM and uh the
king Prince Charles then came along and
joined us he he met a few of us as he
entered the building
um he he sat and enjoyed a concert
presented by the Royal Scottish national
Orchestra who came to brimmar so it was
a wonderful event we had a packed
audience as you can imagine mostly
invited guests who came along and um it
was just a great celebration of us of
his time in in bremal and of Classic FM
itself but how how quickly things change
how different it is today from what it
was last weekend
what kind of relationships
um did the queen who I think you also
had had met
um he had a personal connection with her
what sort of relationship did she have
with the towns and Villages surrounding
Balmoral
well I wouldn't claim to have a personal
relationship with her but I certainly
met her on a few occasions but she was
she was part of Bruno Mars annual life
cycle and she would arrive here at the
beginning of August for a summer holiday
she would spend a couple of months
living at the ball model and during that
period
she would take part in in various events
or around the local area
everyone believes that it's a place
where she was very happy and very
relaxed and people visit us to the area
will tell lots of stories about
encountering the queen or other members
of the royal family simply walking
around the town in balatha or walking
around the Hills near bremar it was a
very informal relationship and and it's
something people will miss
you were able though to pay your
respects
um to the queen privately yesterday
weren't you
yes a number of us were very privileged
to to get an invitation to go down the
ball model
and pay our respects to the queen so we
we were told our eyes sometime between
three and five thirty and on uh Saturday
afternoon
um which we which we did and to my
surprise uh we were led into the castle
we walked through uh the corridors and
uh through this door that opened up into
the ballroom and there in the ballroom
was the coffin draped in the standard
and surrounded by a vigil of Two
Soldiers and two members of the local
estate and we were the only people there
and I I had imagined we would go there
and we'd be queuing for ages waiting to
file past the coffin but now we had a
very personal and intimate few minutes
alone with the coffin it was a very
special time
okay
um a memory that will stay with you
um for a very long time thank you very
much indeed for sharing that with us
this morning very much appreciated thank
you